[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAZ SATO: So thank you
for taking your time
for our sessions.
It is infuse your business
with Machine Learning.
I am Kaz Sato.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: And
I'm Lak Lakshmanan.
KAZ SATO: We are going to
have these sessions by us.
Let me introduce
us, myself first.
So I'm Kaz Sato.
I am a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
I have been working at
Google for six years.
And for the last two
years, I have been working
as a developer advocate.
Who is like a evangelist
for developers.
So I usually have my talk
at meet-ups and sessions
[INAUDIBLE].
And talks about the
Google products,
especially for the
data analysis products
such as Google BigQuery and
machine running products.
And for the first
part, I'll direct
you going through the already
basics about the machine
learning and neural networks.
And I will pass the stage
to Lak for the latter part
of the session.
OK?
So I'd like to start
with the question, what
this machine learning?
How many people have used
machine learning in this venue?
About half people,
like 50% of people.
How many people have you
tried a neural network?
It's about 30%.
[INAUDIBLE] It's
kind of average.
I ask these
questions every time.
I have these sessions
in many events.
So maybe usery is less than 10%
if it's a huge or web developer
conference.
Less than 10% has experience
with similar network.
So what is machine learning?
Machine learning
is all about data,
and how to have the
predictive insight
from data by using the
algorithms of machine learning.
Machine learning algorithms.
So rather than going
through the scanning
of all the passed data, you want
to have a predictive insight.
You want to predict
about the future,
based on the past
history of the data.
To do that, you want to use the
machine learning algorithms.
That is using the
different computing power
from the existing IoT systems.
So let me start with a very
interesting demonstration
called, Playground,
to understand
what is the difference
between the usual IoT
systems and the
machine learning.
If you have this kind of data
set, how do you classify them?
What kind of the
program code you
would try to classify
these two data points?
Well we have x1 and x2.
Two inputs.
And if you plot the
data points, you
can see there are two groups,
blue groups and orange groups.
Maybe you can think
them of a number
of the heights and number
of the weights of people.
So that you can have
the group of adults
where people have the higher
heights and the higher weights.
And people of the children
where you have the lower
weights and lower heights.
And if you are a
programmer, and you
are asked to classify these
two groups of the data points,
you may want to draw a diagonal
line like this at the arbitrary
position.
To check different thresholds,
whether each data point exceeds
the threshold or not.
If it exceeds the threshold,
you must be an adult.
If it is not exceeding the
threshold, you must be a child.
But the thing is that with
the traditional IT systems,
all the programmers are
responsible to instruct
computers how to solve this
problem within some arbitrary
parameters to work
with and biases.
So by choosing the
right W1, W2 weights,
you can change the angle
of this straight line.
And by choosing the
right bias or threshold,
you can move the
position of the rise.
That is how the usual
programmers write his or call
to solve this problem.
But how then you run networks
can solve these problems?
Let's take a look at
the real demonstration.
Where is it?
I lost it.
I think I closed the windows
when I finished last talk.
Sorry about that.
Machine Learning
and demonstration.
This is a very interesting
demonstration called,
Playground, where you can
design your own neural network
inside the browser and
train it in real time.
And here we have
the one neuron here.
So it is not [INAUDIBLE].
It's just the neurons we have.
And we have two inputs,
X1 and X2, as an input.
Features.
And we have a bunch of
the training data here.
And this looks at how the
neuron network can be trained
by using the training data.
You see if I click the
Training start button,
then gradually the
diagonal line tries
to move to classify the data
points in a correct way.
Usually the initial
parameters are randomly
selected in machine
learning algorithms.
But the optimization algorithms
of the machine learning
tries to tweak the parameters,
W1, W2, and biased to find
the best way to draw a straight
line to classify these points.
So if you are a
programmer, maybe you
think that it's
much faster to write
a program called
unspecified asserting
weights and biases by yourself.
But you do not in
machine learning.
You let the computer
think for itself to find,
what's the answer.
That's much better.
So what the neuron data is to
choose the right combination
of the weights and biases.
So what the neuron data
is exactly the same things
you would have done
when you're writing--
solving a
classification problem.
So the single neuron
takes any number
of the inputs like
x1, x2, to xn.
And multiply those
inputs with the weights.
Record weight, w1, w2, wn.
And multiply the
inputs with weights.
And that's exactly
the same things
you would have done
with your program code.
But the huge difference
here is that you
let the computer
try to find the best
combination of the parameters.
By using these
technologies, you can even
have a single neuron classify
a handwritten text image.
If you have a bunch
over handwritten text
image in gray scale, you can
just use a single neuron.
You don't have to build a
whole sophisticated deep
in your own network.
You could just have
a single neuron
to classify those images.
How do you do that?
At first, you have to convert
all the gray scale images
into a bunch of the numbers.
So as you can see
this gray scale image,
which has 20 times--
28 and 28 dimensions--
you can convert them as 784
numbers in a single vector.
And put them all into
a neural network,
or a neuron as an input
of [INAUDIBLE] a neuron.
And [INAUDIBLE] is the
rates from w1 to W784.
And takes the summation
of everything.
So it's very basic,
simple mathematics.
And if the value
of the summation
exceeds certain
thresholds, you can
think that image must be
a digit 1 or a digit of 8.
Just like that.
And by 20 the neural network
by using the [INAUDIBLE]
of the training images,
handwritten text,
you can have a neural network
generate a very unique pattern.
As you can see on the screen.
Where these are the patterns
you can see in the weights
after the training.
Where the blue cover
represents the positive value,
and a red cover represents
the negative body.
So for example,
if you take a look
at your weights for
the number zero,
you can see these zero-like
patterns, group patterns.
It's automatically
generated in the weights.
And historically, if you want
to do the image analytics
or imagery combinations,
those professional
for image [INAUDIBLE]
has been trying
to find the best filters,
or patterns, to detect
any objects in the images.
So that is where the people,
the human programmers,
have to put all the narratives
and experience on that.
But the most important
thing is what's
happening in the
AI booming right
now, is we are now letting
the neural networks to find,
what would be the best pattern,
best filter, to classify
this problem.
So you don't have to have
human programmers to generate
those viridis.
These viridis are
automatically generated.
And after applying
those ways as viridis
and adding in some biases--
and you can get the
result like this
if you have the image of seven.
The probabilities for the 7
would be the highest like this.
And I was talking
about a single neuron,
so you can use the single
neurons to recognize
a handwritten text like I said.
Like I explained.
And now, you can have more and
more neurons between the input
data and output data to make
the neural network much smarter.
This is called hidden layer.
What is that?
LAK LAKSHMANAN:
They're having fun.
KAZ SATO: They are ecstatic.
Let me open the
second demonstrations.
So I need just three neurons
to solve this problem.
So here we have a single,
hidden layer here.
And we have three neurons
in the hidden layers.
And we have another
problem here.
The training data for
classifying the problem.
Where have a bunch of blue
dots inside this circle
made up of the orange group.
And for humans it's really easy
to understand the underlying--
the patterns in the
training data set.
So you can watch the data
set, and you can easily
tell that the blue is
inside the orange group.
It's easy.
But it's not so easy
for the programs
to understand this pattern.
Especially for
the single neuron,
because a single neuron can
only draw us a straight line
in the 2D space.
So it can classify the
problems into a two spaces.
It's so-called linear
classification.
But this is not-linear problem.
This is a nonlinear problem.
So here we have to use the
hidden layers to [INAUDIBLE].
So by starting the training
of the neuron network,
you can see the neural
network gradually trying
to capture the patterns
hidden inside the data set.
[INAUDIBLE]
Let me try it again.
So you'll seeing the
computer is trying
to find the optimal way
to capture the patterns.
And if you take a look at
what each neurons are doing,
then you can see each
neuron is doing very
simple linear classification.
For example, these
particular neurons
just draw the [INAUDIBLE] lines
to classify each data point is
in a blue area or white area.
OK.
This neuron is doing the
same as drawing a straight
and do the linear
classifications.
Whether the data point
is in the left or right?
And that's it.
So very simple.
But having the [INAUDIBLE]
layers of neurons,
you can have the neurons
in the higher layer.
Here we have a single
neuron as an output layer.
It can take all the
outputs from the neurons
in the hidden layer, so that it
can make a little bit smarter
decision on classifying
the data points.
It can listen to
what each neuron is
saying, from the first layer,
and make a final decision.
Because this neuron
is saying this thing,
this neuron says this things.
So that the final neuron can
make a much smarter decision,
like this.
And if you put more
and more neurons here,
the decision would
be much more smarter.
So, as you see, now
the neural networks
is smart enough to capture the
very sophisticated [INAUDIBLE]
inside the data set.
So what do hidden layers do?
Hidden layers is a mapping
inputs to a feature space
and classify with a hyperplane.
And this diagram says so
much about this statement.
So if we have the complex
problem like this,
you can not use single
neurons to classify this,
because it cannot be classified
by the single [INAUDIBLE].
So that you may want to have the
neurons in the hidden layers.
Neurons in the hidden layers
can tweak the input data
to make it easier
for the finer neurons
to classify the
data with divinia
classification like this.
So the pioneer neuron can
just draw a straight line
to classify this or
tweak the data set.
Again, if you have this
kind of nonlinear data set
by having the three hidden
neurons in the hidden layer,
neurons can tweak the data.
So that it tries to make it
easier for the final neuron
to draw a straight--
No, flat plane in the 3-D
space like a flat plane
here to classify the red
part and the blue part.
There's another
image and that tells
about how the hidden layer
can tweak the data to extract
the future set.
You see, even if you have a very
complex structure inside data
set, the hidden layer
can try to tweak
the data in every dimension
to make it classifiable.
So by using these
technologies, you
can even have this double
spiral problem recognized
by the neural networks.
Let's take a look at the
actual demonstration for this.
You go to the third
demonstrations.
Here we have much complex--
Now we have the
three hidden layers.
And the data set is
much more complex.
It's a called double spiral.
So as long as you are using
the traditional IT programming
language, it's really harder
to solve this problem.
If you have to solve this
problem by using the Java
or Python with the ordinary
programming paradigm,
do you want to write many
statements with many thresholds
to check whether each data
point is in this area?
Or this area?
Maybe you can do that by writing
ten [INAUDIBLE] statements,
but I wouldn't do that.
Instead, I want to use neural
networks to solve this problem.
Because by taking
some time, especially
computing power and
training data set,
the computer can gradually
extract the hidden patterns
inside the data set.
Just like you're
watching right now.
So initially, the neural
networks cannot understand
what's going on
inside the data set.
But if you keep teaching
the neural networks,
than the neural network tried
to tweak all the weights
and biases.
Increasing or
decreasing each weights
and biases a little
bit, and see which
direction would be the best way
to converge all the weights--
combination of
weights and biases.
And now, you see the neural
network training is converging.
And now you get neural
networks smart enough
to solve this problem.
And again, if you take a
look at what each of neurons
are doing in your
neural networks,
the neurons in the
[INAUDIBLE] layer
are doing very simple things.
Draw a straight line and
classify the data points
in two areas.
The neurons in the
second layer are doing
a really, really smart thing.
These neurons can
recognize a little bit
more complex pattern.
And in the third layer, you
can see much smarter neurons.
And output layer, you
could have a single failure
that is smart enough to
classify it as a spiral
just like humans do.
So this is how the
neural network works.
And this is the reason why
the deep neural networks
can sometimes exceed
human performance.
Because it's not
instructed by humans.
As long as you keep instructing
computers how to solve
a particular problem, it cannot
exceed human performance.
But if you let the computers
try to find the best
way to solve a
particular problem,
sometimes it's
possible that computers
can find the best way
to extract the feature
to solve its problems.
So that was my part.
So I'd like to pass this Lak.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Thank you Kaz.
So my name is Lak.
I'm part of the
professional services
organization at Google.
And I've been doing machine
learning pretty much
all my career.
So whenever I see this slide,
it always sets me back.
Because the very first thing
that I did out of college--
I used to work at NOAA, the
US Weather Research Agency.
And building models,
and I started out
doing image-processing.
So when Kaz said, people
would write filters,
that people was me.
Right?
So out of college, I was
writing image-processing filters
to find thunderstorms
and radar images.
And we'd basically develop
all of these image-processing
filters by hand.
My PhD was in
texture processing.
And so when you then
go ahead, and you
look at a deep neural net--
And you basically say, when
you look at a deep neural net,
the first part of a neural
net are about basically
finding edges.
You're basically finding
very simple shapes,
and the next part
of the neural net
is about finding more
complex shapes, and so on.
My work was, essentially,
probably around the third layer
of the neural network.
But if you go look at modern
day image classification neural
network, the number of
layers ranges to about 130,
140 layers.
So you can imagine what
goes through my mind
every time I look at
modern neural network.
And to basically think, we were
working on these such things
very primitively.
The second part of the
story is, of course,
neural networks have been
around since the 1970s.
So we could have used neural
networks, where I did.
And I did.
I basically did.
We did a whole bunch of
things with neural networks.
And I remember a
conversation, many years ago,
where we said, hey instead of
us was doing all these filters
by hand, why did they just throw
the raw pixels out of our radar
images into a neural network
and have it figure it out?
And then we all had a big laugh,
because how could you ever get
the computational power required
to throw your raw pixels
into your neural network?
Can you imagine the number of
layers that it's going to need?
How on earth are you going
to program a neural network
to optimize hundreds of layers?
I mean, come on, right?
This is ridiculous.
We would have to
go back and start
designing our filters again.
Fast forward a few years,
and here we are, right?
Where, basically, we can now
launch a Jupiter notebook,
and we basically have one of my
colleagues here doing a demo,
right?
That basically trains on 1,000
images to classify flowers.
He gets the entire demo
done in like an hour.
You basically can classify a set
of images, get it all trained,
and you basically move on to
the next thing in your life.
That's essentially what
the cloud gives you, right?
The combination of
machine learning
and the computational
power of the cloud,
is what allows us to solve
that kind of problem.
So where Kaz is a
developer advocate,
he's basically goes out.
And his role at Google
is to basically get
everybody enthusiastic
about doing things.
And basically explaining
how neural networks work,
and how he can do them.
I'm on the professional
services end.
And the people I deal
with are always asking,
so what kind of
problems can it solve?
What can I do with it?
Right?
And my answer is, hint--
it's about the alternative.
It's about the things
that were alternative when
I started in my career, right?
Instead of using
a neural network,
the alternative was that
I wrote heuristic rules,
image-processing filters.
But that same concept
carries through to a variety
of other situations.
Here, for example,
is Descartes Labs.
Descartes Labs is
one of GCP customers.
That wanted to basically
look at Landsat imagery.
So now you have
Landsat imagery, they
want to look at the imagery.
And looking at the imagery, they
wanted to basically determine
how much corn or soybean
yield was going to happen
across the entire country.
Because commodity's prices,
a variety of things,
depend on how much food
actually gets grown.
Well, by looking at these
Landsat images, right?
Even before the
harvest happened.
They were able to
basically predict
the corn yield and
the soybean yield,
and they were able to do it five
months before the actual USDA
report came out that said,
this is how much got done.
Right?
You basically changed the input.
The input used to be-- you
harvested all of the stuff,
and you measured how
much went to market.
Instead, the input for
Descartes Labs was--
let's just image the Earth.
Let's use the
images of the Earth
to basically figure out
where all the farms are
and how much--
Look at the greenery content.
Look at how these things change.
And they could use
historical data.
They had previous years
of data from a variety
of different locations,
and they could basically
use that to train their model.
And they could basically
do the prediction.
So the first thing
to think about
is-- is there a
different way to do it?
Right?
One way to do it would be
to basically wait, and wait
for the analysis.
Wait for the data
to get collected.
The other way is to say, can
this information that I'm
going to be doing, can I
get it from some other way?
And this some other
way for Descartes Labs
was Landsat images.
So these kinds of
use-cases are all
across a variety of industries.
So whether you're
in manufacturing,
you're in travel, you're in
retail, you're an energy,
you're basically looking at what
data do I have And how can I
use that data to basically go
ahead and predict or estimate
something that I
don't already know?
Or something that I will know--
like in Descartes Labs, they
would know the corn yield.
Except it would take them
five months to know it.
And this is the way to basically
get to know it earlier.
By taking advantage of data.
And as Kaz pointed out,
the thing to realize
is that, don't get
constrained by the way
you're doing things now.
The way a human would solve it--
Right?
Is not necessarily the way
the computer would solve it.
So you can easily imagine
feeding a computer
a different type of
data set than the one
that you're currently doing
and using for analysis.
So think about the data that is
somewhat predictive, somewhat
correlated with what's
actually the thing that you
want to predict.
OK?
So remember I started out
by saying think about it.
It's about the alternative.
Eric Schmidt-- you
all heard him today.
An amazing speaker.
When I grow up, I want to speak
as well as Eric Schmidt speaks.
So Eric Schmidt, last
year at GCP Next--
he basically talked
about machine learning.
He said machine learning-- this
is the next transformation.
It's the next transformation
for a lot of companies.
And the programming paradigm,
the way we program stuff,
is going to change.
The way we program stuff
today is that we write rules.
We write if, then rules.
We write loops, we
write iterations,
we write logic
into our programs.
And Eric Schmidt is saying,
that's going to change.
Instead of programming
a computer,
you're going to show it
a bunch of data, right?
You're going to basically
tell it to learn something.
And the computers is basically
going to then do what you want.
This is an interesting
quote, because he
has lots of fully-formed
thoughts here
about what machine learning is.
But there is no word in
there about the thing
that we normally think of
as machine learning, which
is learning from data.
He's basically taking--
where do you start?
Think about the
heuristics and the rules
that you currently
base your business on,
and see if you can do those
things in a different way.
So it's about the logic.
Figure out what you want
to do differently, and then
collect the data you
need to do it that way.
Right?
So start, not with the data--
start with the problem
you want to solve.
The problem you
often want to solve
is a problem of scalability.
Because human heuristics,
hand-coded heuristics,
don't really scale very well.
So this is basically born
out of Google experience.
The way Google
search used to work
was you would go
to the search bar--
and because someone
would say giants.
And we need to show
you some results.
And as we all know, the
top results on Google
are very valuable.
Right?
So we want to be very thoughtful
about what is the top result.
We want to give our
searchers the right result.
So the way we
would do this was--
well somebody
searched for giants.
Do we return them,
San Francisco Giants?
Or do we return them,
New York Giants?
Well there was a rule.
And the rule was if
the query are Giants,
and if the user is
located in the Bay Area,
show them results about
San Francisco Giants.
If the query is Giants, and the
user is located in New York,
show them results
about New York Giants.
If the user is not in the Bay
Area, user is not in New York,
show them results
about big, tall people.
Right?
That was basically the rule that
was in the Google search engine
for one query about giants.
Think about how many queries
happen for every sports team,
for every river.
Someone searches
for the Red River
there in Texas, we
show you the river
between Oklahoma and Texas.
If the person is in Minnesota,
we show you the Minnesota Red
River, right?
So every geographic feature--
stadiums, names of businesses,
right?
And this is just about location.
This is just about location.
You have so many other
cues about your interests.
So you can easily imagine--
just imagine how big and complex
and hairy that code base gets.
That's not tractable.
And that's when
RankBrain came along.
So RankBrain was let's
not hard code rules.
Instead, let's see if we can
do things in a better way.
We have data, right?
We know that when we
show people results,
we know what they
actually clicked on.
And let's use it to train a
model to basically predict
using a whole host of inputs.
Let's make a network to
go ahead and predict.
What the top result ought to be.
So we were replacing all
of those heuristic rules
by a neural network.
And that neural network,
as soon as it got released,
it essentially became the
third most important signal
among hundreds of
signals that decide
what the ranking of the page
is going to be on the Google
search result.
That's basically
what Eric Schmidt
is driving at when he says that
machine learning is a new way
of programming, right?
Because what we're doing is
that we are replacing the way
we do logic.
We are replacing
the way we do logic.
And starting with that, knowing
you're successful in the thing
that the company is most famous
for, everybody takes notice.
Right?
So four years ago,
in 2012, there
was pretty much no deep learning
modules in Google, right?
As of quarter for 2016, we
are basically at 4,000 models.
And this is all over
all of Google products.
Apps, Gmail, Maps, Photos.
You guys have seen
it everywhere.
And it's becomes this thing
that you basically get everybody
in this mindset
of, we maybe doing
things using a seat
of the pants rule now,
but we're going to
collect the data.
So we can do it with
machine learning later.
That's essentially going to be
the approach that every product
team takes.
Every product team
essentially says,
how can we solve
this problem with ML,
so we don't have to
keep writing rules.
And handling
specific situations.
And specific-- if this, if
that, all those situations.
We want to avoid that
by doing ML, right?
So you basically get
into this process of,
how do I collect the data?
So my point here is that
you start with the problem
you want to solve.
Think about the
scalability of your logic,
and then think
about what data you
need to collect to solve it.
First way-- if you are to infuse
your business with machine
learning, the first thing to do
is to rethink your user input.
Right?
Rethink you user input.
What do I mean by that?
Well, you on one hand
have custom machine
learning models, with
TensorFlow, Machine Learning
Engine, with just
[INAUDIBLE] today, right?
So you can basically build your
own machine learning models.
On the other hand, building
your own machine learning models
requires lots and
lots and lots of data.
So when we talk about--
you want to build an image
classification model, you
need millions of images.
But we have ways to,
basically, do things
with fewer images, right?
We also have what are
pre-trained machine learning
models.
The Vision API, which
is basically already
knows how to classify
lots of images.
We have the Speech
API, which already
knows how to transcribe text.
It is a waste of your
time and resources
to go build a speech model.
You might just use ML
model, that we have trained
over lots and lots of data.
So when you look at our video
API that got demoed today,
that's not on the slide yet.
Right?
So that's basically
on-trained on so many more
videos than it's even possible
for you to think about.
Right?
There are better
things for you to do.
All of us that are
in businesses--
we have core focus.
So those are the things
that we want to focus on.
The things that Google has done,
you want to take advantage of.
And that's where the
pre-trained models come in.
So number one, let
your users talk to you.
The days when you could have
expected your users to come in
and type are gone.
OK.
These days, if I
want to go somewhere,
I'm basically on
Google Maps, right?
I pretty much never, ever
type the name of the place
I'm going to.
It's all just voice
search, right?
Especially because
I'm on the go.
It is completely,
completely voice search.
And maybe I'm on
the leading edge,
but a huge fraction of searches
on mobile happen through voice.
And when you build applications,
increasingly, your users
are going to expect
the same thing.
So for example, there's
a company called, AUCNET,
which wanted to basically
build the system that
needed to figure out how
much is my car worth.
So people have done
this before, right?
But what AUCNET said was, I'm
going to rethink my user input.
And what I'm going to do is--
you want to figure out how
much your car is worth,
take a photograph of your car.
Take a photograph of the front
of your car, of your dashboard,
of the back, of the
sides, everything.
Take a bunch of photographs.
Send it to us.
We'll tell you how
much the car is worth.
so from the photographs,
AUCNET that would determine
the model of the car, who
made the car, which year it
was, the condition of the
car, all of that stuff.
And tell you this
is what it's worth.
Now put yourself in
somebody's situation, right?
You're a consumer.
You have two possible websites.
One website gives you a
form that's two pages long.
And at their website says, send
me a couple of photographs.
You obviously see that now ML
is a competitive advantage.
Rethink your user input.
Your user input doesn't
need to be forms.
Right?
Your user input doesn't
need to be forms.
How many of you
use Google Forms?
Quite a few of you, right?
And have you noticed
that recently when
you're creating a Google form--
you can say, for example.
You ask a question, when
do you want to meet?
And it auto suggests answers.
Right?
It auto suggests
possible answers
that helps your
dynamically built stuff.
Right?
And that's essentially
the kind of stuff
that we're talking about.
We're talking about being
able to know and limit
the amount of user input that
somebody has to give you.
Because you can guess
what their next question
or the next answer
is going to be.
Here's another example of
using images to take action.
The application is
called Meeting Nanny.
OK.
Which basically has a
camera on a conference room.
The same camera that's used
for video conferencing.
Again, it's connected
to the calendar.
So all it does is basically
looks at the room.
So the meeting was supposed
to start seven minutes later.
Nobody has shown up.
It will release the room so
somebody else can come use it.
So using images to take action.
The user input here is
all completely automated.
But it's an image.
It's an image.
It's an image of the
room, so it can figure out
if you can do this or not.
Another customer for us, Ocado.
The way Ocado used to work
was-- somebody sent an email.
You had somebody sit
there, read the email.
Figure out what was in the
email and decide what to do.
The way they do it now is that
they use the natural language
processing, API.
Again, a pre-built model,
the NLP, API model.
They were able to use that.
And they can use that model
to basically say, oh, here's
an email that came
in, and this email
is a customer
expressing satisfaction.
So this is what I need to do.
This is something
that's about billing.
The customers is
frustrated about building,
so I need to send it to
somebody who handles billing.
So an email comes
into the company,
it automatically gets triaged,
sent to the right department.
This is the kind of stuff
that your customers are
going to increasingly expect.
Right?
You're not going to
be able to get away
with form responses that
are just boilerplate stuff.
It needs to be really, really,
really meaningful responses.
And you can do this.
You can do this now
with machine learning.
Another example
here, lots of us,
when we build applications--
We ask for customer images.
That's a scary thing.
Because we are all working in a
variety of different industries
that have regulatory stuff.
So here's a customer that
wanted to basically prevent
violent images from
being uploaded.
OK.
And they also wanted to
prevent unsafe for work images.
And here's an example of
the Vision API at work.
It's able to focus in on
the image on the left,
and say, OK, this is
actually a safe image.
It's just showing a
couple on a beach.
But the image on the
right, it basically
flags as being unsafe.
And it turns out,
that if you look
at what the machine learning
algorithm is focusing on--
that's the yellow stuff
and the red stuff.
It's focusing on the finger
of the person holding the gun,
and apparently that person
is squeezing the trigger.
So this is showing
somebody actually
in the process of shooting.
Knows that this is
now a violent thing
and removing that violent scene.
It's at that level of crispness.
Is what ML operate at.
Another thing that you can do.
So he can re-imagine
your user inputs.
That's one thing, right?
You basically look at images.
Treat images as bonafide inputs.
Think of speech
as bonafied input.
Your input doesn't just
need to be text, right?
That's what we
normally think of.
We're writing
computer programs--
If they are input, it's text.
It doesn't need to
be text anymore.
It can be images.
It can be audio.
But the other thing that
you may want to think about
is your business
processes themselves.
Re-imagine the way you
do your business process.
Change your business process.
What do you mean by that, right?
So if you're thinking about
ML as a rocket engine.
The thing that can
take you places.
The fuel is going to be data.
As long as you have data,
you can go places with it.
So what are the kinds of things
that we're talking about,
right?
Your typical customer journey
here in business processes--
your typical customer
journey is to go look
at any kind of manual
thing that you are doing.
And seeing if you can do that
manual think in a better way.
So this is global fishing
watch, another GCP customer.
And they basically
would do manual analysis
of global fishing fleets.
So the idea was that they would
look at where the ships are.
Basically figure out
how often the ships had
gone to a particular
region to, basically,
see if that region
was being overfished.
Whether somebody was
fishing above their quota.
Whether somebody was using the
fishery resources more often
than they should.
Or that they are going
into protected waters.
All of that kind of stuff.
And they would do this.
They had manual analyst
doing this all the time.
Some of that stuff
could be automated.
And that's what they did, right?
So with machine learning,
you could basically--
think about a lot of things
that were done manually.
They didn't automate
the whole thing,
but they could
basically automate
different stages of it.
To, basically, then
allow the analysts
to basically bring their
experience and expertise
to the parts that
really mattered.
And basically make the routine
stuff so much more easier,
so that it could
be done with ML.
OK.
So the typical customer
journey often here
involves find the things
that your analysts are doing.
The things that they hate doing.
Because they come
in the morning,
and they're just doing the
same thing over and over again.
They get tired, because
it's very repetitive.
And there's the kinds of
things that you can automate.
Because, A, you have
the results of all
of that manual analysis
that stretches back
many, many, many years.
That's the key thing, right?
What you're thinking
about is what kind of data
do you have so you can
actually automate it.
So the data that
you will have is
because you've done this
analysis in a manual way
for so long.
You, basically, may have five
years, 10 years, 15 years--
how many years your
business has been around.
Or how many years your
industry has been around.
Of the results of
that manual analysis.
And you can basically take
all of the inputs that
go into manual analysis,
and you take the outcome,
and it can train
an ML model on it.
Because all you need is
the input and the outcome.
Don't worry about,
oh, in order to do
this person looked at this other
thing, and all of that stuff.
That's fine.
That may be the way
the human did it,
but the ML model may be
able to basically hone in
on other things that
are representative
of the situations in concerned.
But when you're
talking about data,
most of our data analysis,
as humans, most of our data
analysis often--
if you go to look at our data
scientists or data engineers.
Our data analysts
in the company.
What kind of data are
they dealing with?
Relational databases.
They're dealing with
structured data.
But in a typical
company, 90% of your data
will be unstructured data.
What do you mean by
unstructured data?
Emails.
Tons of information
in your e-mails.
Reports.
Lots and lots of
information when
somebody goes to a
field site and writes
a whole bunch of field notes.
What are you doing with
that data right now?
It's your company's data, but
you can't do anything with it.
Because, A, you're thinking
I cannot actually put it
in the structured form.
So I can write a
SQL query on it.
But that's where ML can help.
ML can help you find insight
from unstructured data.
But unstructured data is hard.
Unstructured data is hard.
OK, I did an ML
BootCamp yesterday.
And we basically talked about
how to do structured data.
Because that's easy.
When you're doing
a BootCamp, you
want to show people
how to do things--
the easy thing.
Right?
Let's get started with ML.
We'll get started
with structured data.
Unstructured data,
images, speak, text.
Those are hard.
Those are very hard.
That's where you
basically go higher PhDs.
To come do the
work for you there.
Right?
But you don't need to
do that all the time.
Because what you can
do is that you can
take your unstructured data.
Whether it's images, whether
it's audio, whether it's video,
whether it's free
form text, and you
can use the pre-trained
of models out of GCP.
The Vision API for images.
What is it going to do?
It's going to look at
your image and tell you
what's in the image.
It's going to tell
you this image
has a mountain pass in it.
This image has a [INAUDIBLE]
in it, et cetera.
It's going to tell
you what's in it.
And you can also build on
top of our image models
to basically classify your
own particular things.
You want to basically determine
that this image contains
part number 8341.
No problem, right?
Give us enough images
of parts 8341 and 8348.
And we can basically tell
you which one's which.
Which one is a four inch
screw, and which one
is a six inch screw.
Those are pretty easy if you
build on top of our models.
So you can do images that way.
You have audio.
Use a Speech API.
And you basically take
that and it'll you text.
So what do you do
with that text?
It's free form text.
And if you have free form text,
use a natural language API.
So what the natural
language API will do
is-- a given free form
text, it will tell you
who's mentioned, what's
mentioned, the sentiment.
It'll tell you this is a full
sentence, this is a phrase,
these are the links between
these things, and so on.
Right?
So you can basically do that.
You can do video.
We just saw that.
So all of those APIs
essentially give you
places, labels, people, events,
sentiment, and at that point
that is a perfect thing
to go ahead and feed
into your custom-machine
learning model.
And now, it's not as
hard a problem anymore.
Because you're now dealing with
essentially-structured data.
And you're basically
deriving insight from it.
We've done the
hard part of going
from unstructured data to
things that you can now
do your model training on.
The third way that
you can basically
use ML in your business
is to delight your users.
And what I mean by
delight your users
is to basically figure out what
your users want before even
they realize they want.
To basically do that,
that's part of delight.
For example, how
many of you thought
that your email program
had to suggest to you what
the response was going to be?
But now, 20% of all
users of inbox--
and now Gmail also has it.
Right?
20% of all responses
on mobile to an email
start out with the Smart reply.
How many of you have
used Smart reply.
Still getting out there, right?
20%.
It's still 20%.
Basically, the way it
works is you get an email,
and the email program,
inbox or Gmail,
suggest to you with
three possible responses
to that email.
So for example, in
this particular email,
this guy says, can
you send me something?
And basically, the
three responses
are-- one of them is
I'm working on them.
The second one is I
just sent them to you.
And the third one
is no plans yet.
Three pretty good responses
that cover the spectrum.
So you can start with that.
You basically saved the
person three words of typing.
So this can apply to your
business as well, right?
If somebody comes, and they ring
the bell in your grocery shop,
and you already know that the
location that they're in--
the shelf is empty.
You can actually delight
them by saying, we realize
that we are out of
product x, would you
like us to give you, right?
These are the
three alternatives.
You can take a rain check,
we can offer you a discount
on another product, et cetera.
Imagine how the
user's experience
is going to be different from--
they call in, and we
basically have them wait.
Instead of running them through
the rigmarole, the moment
they basically say, I need help.
At this point, you basically
realize what help they need.
Because you know what they
are currently experiencing.
We are probably seeing some
of that already, right?
These days when my
flight gets delayed,
I automatically get rebooked
and the airline companies
are already doing that.
That's the kind of stuff that
we're talking about, right?
You know what your
customers are experiencing.
Basically, solve right there.
Many things don't have to go
through the normal business
process.
If you know what they
are, you can predict it.
Now in terms of solving a
problem that you didn't know
existed, right?
In a completely
different fancy way.
Lots of people create their
own home videos, right?
And they want to put a
background music track on it.
When you're putting a background
music track on that video,
what do what do people do?
They basically get
a popular track,
and they throw it
onto the video.
And then YouTube
basically shuts it down,
because of a
copyright violation.
Because you're using music
that you shouldn't be using.
But ML is now good enough
that you can basically
go to a video.
And you can basically
say, I would
like you to generate
music for me that's jazz.
That is low key for the
first three minutes,
it crescendos between minutes
3 and 3.30, comes back down,
and then basically
ends with a flourish.
And that music
can get generated.
It'll be jazz.
It won't be Wynton
Marsalis for any means.
But it'll be pretty darn
good for a home video.
Those are the kinds of things
that we're talking about,
right?
I'm so excited about
what ML can do.
I'm so excited about what
you guys can do with ML.
So thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]